mi az aminek aminek örvendenünk kell
mint udvarhelyieknek hú mindennek
gyakorlatilag nem is fogjuk fel hogy
milyen hihetetlen módon elkényeztetettek
vagyunk mi itt udvarhely konkrétan
udvarhely
európa románia is de hogy udvarhely
egyszerűen szerintem a tökéletes hely
persze borzasztóan lokálpatrióta vagyok
ez is beszél belőlem de hogyha elkezdjük
kielemezni azt hogy mit tud ez a város
nyújtani akkor
illetve felírjuk egy lapra akkor
mérlegeljük hogy akkor mi a pro mi a
kontra nem igazán tudok kontrát mondani
nem igazán tudok olyat mondani amire azt
mondanám hogy na ezért nem élnék
udvarhelyen tehát nincs ilyen